[MUSIC PLAYING]
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: Good morning,
everybody, everybody here
in the room and then,
of course, everybody
watching on live stream or
later watching on YouTube.
My name is Fontaine
Foxworth and I'll
be walking you through
today how to best take
advantage of the Places API,
which is the technology that's
responsible for
actually distributing
semantic information
about places to you
as developers with
widely different needs.
Now, first I want to
start with the word place.
When I joined the team, I asked,
what exactly does place mean?
And I was met with giggles.
Well, it depends on who you
talk to, was the response I got.
We discussed, was there
a more appropriate word
or perhaps a more precise
word to describe places?
And over the coming
weeks, I really
started to grow pretty
fond of the word.
You see, place
does mean something
different to everybody.
But there are a couple
of common trends.
Place is a place fundamentally
because we as humans
assign value to it.
And Google cares deeply
about understanding
these places that are
living and breathing
and updating all the time.
And so we take it upon us
to have an up-to-date record
of these places.
Now, I moved to Sydney,
Australia back in February.
And when I got off
the plane, I felt
similar to how I imagine
this girl here feels.
She's getting her bearings,
orienting herself.
She's on a path.
And in the same way, I,
when I arrived in Australia,
adjusted my own internal GPS
and tried to get familiar
with my context.
So I would bike around
different neighborhoods,
drink flat whites in
different coffee shops
or read in bookstores.
I was getting to know
the place of Australia
but I was also getting to
know neighborhoods and streets
and shops.
Now, I'll be taking
you on a journey today.
And this will go in
three different phases.
The first phase I want
to actually explore
what it means to be a place.
We have this location stack
that has all different levels
of metadata about a place.
And I'm going to talk you
through how you can actually
access different types of
metadata about our places.
Secondly, we'll be exploring
several real-world applications
and then the corresponding
services within the Places API
that you can use to
actually meet those cases.
And then finally,
I'll be talking
through how this is
best accomplished
through our mobile SDKs.
So now actually diving into that
location stack, when we first
started mapping the
world, it was largely
about charting courses.
And so a latitude and a
longitude and some math
was usually enough to get
from point A to point B.
But this isn't
necessarily the best way
that we as humans
understand the world.
I'm showing you here a set
of coordinates, a latitude
and a longitude, 37.4
something degrees
latitude, negative
122.1 degrees longitude.
My guess is, upon
first seeing this,
you don't automatically
know where it is.
Now, this is certainly
helpful to us
and certainly as we input
this kind of information
into computer that's powerful,
for example, in a mapping API
to actually plot on a
map where this point is.
We'll come back to those
specific coordinates
in a minute.
But then we actually started to
structure the world around us.
We started to have postal codes
or house numbers or streets,
basically addresses.
And addresses were
certainly powerful
in helping us structure and
understand the world around us
and critical for systems
like postal services
where we're trying
to get a letter
to a specific destination.
But as humans, we don't usually
remember more than a couple
of addresses.
I know my own home address,
maybe my parents' address.
But beyond that I really
don't have any more.
So there must be a better way
for us to actually understand
places in the world.
Now, if we go back to those
coordinates we saw earlier
and we added an additional
layer of metadata, the address,
we can start to understand
a little bit more
about this place, right?
It's an amphitheater.
It's in Mountain View.
I'm starting to get
a little bit more
of a characterization
about that place.
But we as humans fundamentally
understand and memorize
the world around us
with semantic places
and their characteristics.
So here is an image of Shoreline
Amphitheater actually taken
At google I/O last year.
I know that I'm
sitting somewhere
in the back right, up on
the line there probably,
when this image was taken.
And so when we add that next
layer of metadata onto those
coordinates we saw
earlier, we see
that I was, in fact, talking
about Shoreline Amphitheater.
So now this place becomes
a lot more real to us.
I understand this as a human.
And there's so
much other metadata
that we can associate with
this particular place.
So when it comes to
a sense of place,
it's not just geographic.
It necessitates this
human characterization.
So I've actually started to
fall in love with the word place
precisely because it is
so imprecise, because it
means something
different to everybody.
In fact, that's what
makes it a place at all.
Now, I read a lot.
And my favorite author is a
woman named Rebecca Solnit.
I first encountered her
when I came across an atlas
that she'd written.
And it had 25 different
maps, all of San Francisco.
And each one of these
maps is basically
looking at a different
level or layer of data
about San Francisco and
had a corresponding essay
written about it.
And her big thesis out
of that was basically
a map is not a
canonical definition
or representation of a place.
It's merely a layer
of data that we choose
to represent about a place.
And you can have
infinite maps that
represent a place, which is
why she was creating an Atlas.
So she had a quote
from a different book
which I thought was relevant
and wanted to share.
Places matter.
Their rules, their
scale, their design
include or exclude
civil society.
Pedestrianism, equality,
diversity, they map our lives.
Now, Google's mission is
to organize the world's
information and
make it universally
accessible and useful.
And certainly understanding
physical, real-world places
is critical to this
mission of organizing
the world's information.
But as you can imagine,
it's an immense task
and there's lots of challenges.
So among these
challenges, first of all,
there are hundreds
of millions of places
in the world that
we have a record of,
not to mention the infinite
places that we don't yet
have a record of.
So there's so much
information out there.
Secondly, places have a
very natural life cycle.
Businesses spring up.
Businesses closed down.
We know that about
10% to 15% of places
are turning over every year.
And then, of course, places can
mean so many different things.
So how I would represent an
ATM in our database versus how
I would represent a
cafe or a hospital
would all be very different.
So I need a way to
actually capture
all the nuances of different
types of places while still
creating a scalable system.
So where does Google
get all this data?
We collect data from a
whole variety of sources
and put it in a
single place to make
available to the systems
that are actually
using these objects.
So I'll walk you through
some of those sources now.
The first is Street View.
We have cars driving the
streets of the world taking
360-degree imagery of
the places they're in.
So we can create
immersive experiences
that we've heard a lot
at Google I/O this year.
There's potential for
more virtual experiences.
Having this sort of
360 immersive imagery
is going to be critical to
actually creating those.
And it's not just cars.
We have sometimes bikes giving
360-degree imagery, even
backpackers with 360-degree
cameras trekking the Grand
Canyon.
We also have satellite imagery.
This aerial footage helps us
understand a totally different
aspect of the world and maps.
This is more about
geometry, so understanding
if a building takes up a
certain amount of space,
what's its relationship
to a road, what
are geopolitical entities
and how are they structured?
So getting this sort of imagery
conveys a totally different
lens of data.
There was that movie, Lion,
which came out recently
which I thought was a really
powerful illustration of how
a human could take a technology
like satellite imagery provided
through Google Earth
and actually create
incredible value in his life.
It was a boy named
Saroo who I think
was lost at the age of
five or six in India.
He had actually
gotten onto a train
and ended up hundreds or
thousands of kilometers
away from where he
was being raised.
He ended up being
adopted in Australia.
And decades later, he
went into Google Earth
and was actually able to
track down the train station
that he'd accidentally had
gotten onto the train at
and find his birth family
and reconnect with them.
So a really powerful
way of how we
can take technology as humans
and create value for ourselves.
And then, of course, we
have business owners.
Via Google My Business,
business owners
are able to come in and
actually control how they're
being represented to the world.
So they can make sure their
phone numbers are up to date,
their websites are
the correct ones.
This is an example of
a brewery who did this.
I also connected with a woman
in Sydney a few months ago
who had a bed and
breakfast and needed
help actually getting set
up with Google My Business
because her visitors, the people
who were staying with her,
didn't want written instructions
about how to actually arrive
at her bed and breakfast.
They wanted to just be able
to type it into Google Maps
and have Google Maps
take them there.
So I was able to help
her take ownership
of how her bed and breakfast
is represented on Google Maps
to make sure that
the right address was
there and all the other
information that she needed.
And then, of course, we have
the consumer applications,
Google Maps.
We all probably have
Google Maps in our pocket
and are using it on
a near daily basis.
And we all have the power
to make modifications
to certain place entries.
We can contribute content,
whether reviews or photos.
Here's an illustration of
trying to modify the Shoreline
Amphitheater place.
And I can only imagine that this
particular channel will become
more and more powerful
as Google wants
to empower its users to
help us actually shape
our representation of the world.
And so with all of these
data sources, of which I just
covered four, we are
able to bring them
all into a single place and
understand the relationship
between different objects.
And then we make it, of
course, available to our users
via Google Maps.
But we also make it available
to developers like you
to build cool
experiences on top of.
And that's via the
Places API, which
we'll be diving into some of
the specific applications today.
And before we dive into
those applications,
I want to take a
moment to acknowledge
our primary key within
places, which is the place ID.
This is the ID that helps you
get all of the information
and metadata about a place.
Now, as we talked about, places
can represent establishments
like shops or bookstores.
It can represent
points of interest
like the Statue of Liberty
or the Sydney Opera House.
It could be
geopolitical entities
like Mountain View
or San Francisco,
intersections, roads, addresses.
Places can be so many things.
And the primary
key to all of these
is the corresponding place ID.
Now, there's lots
of ways that we
can characterize the place ID.
But I want to take a
moment to illustrate three.
First, it's unique.
So each key exists exactly once.
Secondly, the place
ID is ubiquitous
and that certainly you can use
it throughout the place API.
But you can also use
it throughout some
of our other mapping
APIs or imagery APIs.
So if I wanted to
get the Street View
imagery for a specific
place, I would just
need to pass in that place ID
to one of our Street View APIs.
Or if I needed to get
directions to a certain place,
I could pass in that place
ID system of our mapping
or navigation APIs.
And then coming back
to that illustration
that we looked at with
Shoreline Amphitheater,
with a single place
ID, I can access
all these different levels
of this location stack
from the latitude and
longitude to an address
to the semantic qualifier
or other metadata
about that place, so again,
the single key that helps us
traverse that stack.
So now let's look at a
couple of illustrations
of how developers
in the real world
are actually trying to meet some
of their place needs or mapping
needs and then the
corresponding services they're
using within our API to
actually accomplish those tasks.
The first I want to
consider is real estate.
And we're looking at some
lovely aerial beach photography
right now.
And since I am currently
living in Australia,
let's assume that we have an
Australian real estate company.
And our user is going to be
searching for a neighborhood
that they're interested in.
For the purposes of
this conversation,
we'll say that our
user is looking
for the neighborhood
called Manly,
which is one of our popular
northern beaches near Sydney.
Now, by using the
autocomplete service,
a user can actually come in
and start typing typing M-a-n.
And then the results
are dynamically
updating as the user's typing.
And then they can
actually select the result
that's most relevant to them.
So we're able to
see that here being
selected with Manly Beach.
Now, to take advantage
of autocomplete,
you can certainly use
our APIs directly.
Or we also have widgets
available on both iOS
and Android where we take care
of some of the UI in addition
to the API logic.
So here's an example
of how you could
put in our fragment with
this XML up at the top here.
And then you can actually call
that in the Java code listed
here at the bottom.
So you can see the place
autocomplete fragment is
the name of that fragment here.
Now, after our user
has identified to us
that they're interested
in searching within Manly,
you probably have a
bunch of listings.
Your real estate
website, you have
a bunch of listings in Manly.
And those listings are
basically addresses,
so you have a list of addresses.
Now, actually, to be able to
plot these addresses on a map,
you need to be able to
tell the computer basically
where to put them.
And the best way to do this
is via our geocoding service.
Now, geocoding is a way
of taking an address
and interpreting that into
a latitude and longitude
that a computer could
then plot on a map.
So here's an example
of 93 West Esplanade,
which is one of our
listings in Manly.
I can take this and convert it
into the corresponding latitude
and longitude, negative
33 degrees latitude,
151 degrees longitude, and
actually plot that on a map.
We, of course, have
the reverse as well
if I'm trying to take a
latitude and longitude
and turn that into an address.
But that would meet
a different set
of use cases, but worth
calling out nonetheless.
So that's our geocoding service.
Here is an illustration
of us making a request
to our geocoding web service.
And it's a Python example.
Basically, you can see
that the formatted address
results are being displayed
to our user in an array here.
So stepping into our next
application, photo tagging.
We know that photos
are a key part
of us experiencing
the world and sharing
our experiences with people.
And one of the first
things that people often
ask when they see an image is,
where was that photo taken?
It's because having a place
associated with an image
gives it that much more context.
It helps you tell the
story about that photo.
So one of the key
questions you're often
asking when you're doing
photo tagging is, where am I
or where's my user?
To answer this question, you
can use our getCurrentPlace API.
This service is
responding with a list
of possible candidates
of where that user is
and a corresponding likelihood
that the user is actually
there.
This is available on mobile.
And I'll be talking
a little bit later
in the conversation about how we
calculate that likelihood, what
type of inputs go into that.
Here's some Android code
about how you could actually
use getCurrentPlace.
And you can see if the
getCurrentPlace call, which
is part of the place
detection API name space.
And we have this callback,
which is an asynchronous call.
And you can see we've got a
buffer that's being returned,
which is the list of places.
And we also have the
corresponding likelihood.
And then, because we're
maintaining the place objects,
you can do things like calling
getName, getLikelihood, getID.
Because we're actually
maintaining that place object,
we're able to provide you
with some helper methods
to manipulate those easily.
One thing to note
is that when it
comes to places and
using places in your app,
you as a developer only really
need to store and maintain
the place ID overtime.
Because as we talked
about earlier,
Google is taking on the project
of actually keeping up-to-date
all of the places in the world.
So we know that these places
are living and breathing.
So we want you as
a developer only
need to keep track of the place
that you're interested in.
And then you continue
to ask us for what
is the most up-to-date
information using that place
ID which we talked about.
We also have a widget
available that's
called the PlacePicker which
fundamentally sits on top
of this getCurrentPlace API.
And you can see how we show
users the different places that
are being returned.
And then you put the
power into the user's hand
to actually select which
place they're actually at.
So instead of just
assuming where they're at,
if you want the user to
identify which place they're at,
you can do that via PlacePicker.
Here's an illustration
of how you can actually
call that on Android.
And then we have the same
thing available on iOS.
The third application that
we're going to be exploring
is travel and hospitality.
And naturally, the
types of questions
that you're trying
to answer when you're
building a travel or hospitality
experience are very different.
And many of these have to do
with discovering places, trying
to understand what's
surrounding me,
what's going on around here.
And to answer this, you
often want to issue a search.
You want to ask us, what's
happening around here?
Now, the search
service is interesting
because the actual set of
results that you would get
varies wildly depending
on what your use
case is, what your inputs are.
Some of the inputs that
can vary can be a string.
What is the actual string
that you're inputting
and how similar is that
to some of the results
that we are returning?
What about proximity?
Are you looking for things
that are close to you?
Or are you looking for
prominence, big, popular cafes
and restaurants around you?
You can also input
different biases
so that we can actually respond
differently or filter down
the actual set of results
that we could be returning.
So I want to illustrate a couple
of different samples of using
the search service and
how that could impact
the results that you would get.
In the first
illustration, if I were
to look for the string Sydney
Opera, that's pretty distinct.
And I'm most likely trying to
get to the Sydney Opera House.
So I would only responded with
one other item, which would
be the Sydney Opera House.
It's pretty navigational.
I know exactly what
I'm looking for.
However, if I searched
for a bookstore
in Sydney, which
is more categorical
and I'm expecting
a list of results,
then I could get
that list of results.
Here's an illustration of
what that could look like.
And because it's
an API, we would
be returning it as a list.
And a key part is
understanding how it's sorted.
How are we actually returning
that information to you?
And you can tell us,
are you more interested
in sorting by
distance and really
having proximity be the focus?
For example, if I'm
looking for bookstores
but I really just want
to get a postcard,
I don't really care
about the bookstore,
I just need to get a
letter to send a friend,
then sorting by proximity
makes a lot of sense.
However, if I'm trying
to get an understanding
of the literary
culture in Sydney,
then I might want to sort
instead by prominence because I
want to understand what the most
prominent bookstores in Sydney
are and prioritize those.
And then as we highlighted
earlier, like a SQL query,
I can actually limit
down my results
by imposing some type
of bias or restriction,
like I only want to see
bookstores that have
a certain star rating or above.
Now, once you've issued a
search using our search service,
you could get a single place
back or a list of places.
So you have a bunch of IDs.
And then the next question is,
tell me more about this place.
What is at this place?
And in order to do that, you
could use our Place Detail
service.
Place Detail service allows
you to basically access
all of the metadata
about a place,
so not just the
basics like an address
or the coordinates, the
latitude and longitude.
But, of course, you can get the
name or the type of a place.
So imagine you're building
a location-based game
and you need to understand
where the bodies of water
are because you want to keep
your users away from bodies
of water and understand where
the parks are because you want
to be driving your
users towards parks.
So understanding types
is really key to actually
being able to shape
your experience.
You can also understand other
characteristics of a place,
see what the star rating is or
how many reviews a place gets.
To use that, you can
call getPlaceByID.
So again, you would
be passing us the ID
and we would be responding
with all of the metadata.
And we have those helper
methods to actually allow
you to do things like getName.
So you can see how we're
first validating here
that we are, in fact, getting
a valid place object back.
And then you can access some
of those helper methods.
So the final part
of our journey is
going to be exploring how
this best manifests itself
within our mobile SDKs.
So certainly places
are available
across several different
platforms including JavaScript
or you could just hit
our web service directly.
But I think places best
are taken advantage
of on the mobile platform,
so within our iOS and Android
SDKs.
And there's three reasons
I want to highlight
about why I think they
are best taken advantage
of in this world.
The first is that we
are able to serve you
more accurate results,
the second being it's
much easier to use.
And then third, they've been
optimized for performance.
So starting with more
accurate results, for this,
I want to focus on the
getCurrentPlace service, which
we talked about earlier.
And we had talked
about photo tagging.
So here's an image of food.
And let's say I want
to be able to associate
a place with this food.
Now, many photos come with
the latitude and longitude
associated with them.
And while this is helpful,
it can be problematic,
I think, in two ways.
One, I would never
post a photo that said,
check out this food that I ate
at insert coordinates here.
That doesn't really tell me
anything about that food.
Secondly, because I was indoors,
the latitude and longitude
might actually not be the
most accurate representation
of where I was.
So it's being displayed here.
But that might not
actually be exactly where
I was at that moment.
Now, if I were to use geocoding,
and this would actually
be an application of reverse
geocoding, which we talked
about earlier, I
could input those
coordinates into
reverse geocoding
and I can get an address back.
Now, while certainly I could
better understand and see
that, OK, this is this
places on Castro Street,
it still doesn't give
me an understanding
of where the food was eaten.
And again, if the inputs of
those latitudes and longitudes
were not accurate to begin with,
then the output of the address
is also not going
to be accurate.
However, with
getCurrentPlace, which
is only available on
mobile, you can actually
understand that we're at the
Morocco's restaurant, which
is across the street,
across Fairmont
avenue, from the latitude and
longitude that we initially
plotted.
And we're able to
understand and infer this
from a variety of
inputs, which I'll
talk you through in a minute.
But this is incredibly
powerful because we're
able to understand more
about some of the inputs that
are there than just
relying exclusively
on the latitude and longitude.
So like with many other
products at Google,
we're able to incorporate
machine learning into actually
understanding how
users are navigating
between these hundreds
of millions of places
that we have access
to within Google.
And so some of those
inputs that actually
are helping us understand are
things like opening hours.
So if I post this photo
in the evening at 8:00 PM
and there was a sports gear
store across the street
but that's sports gear
store closed at 5:00 PM,
it is unlikely that I'm
going to be at that place.
So I'm able to
de-prioritize the fact
that I would be at
that sports gear store
even though from a
geographic point of view,
my point, my latitude and
longitude might look like it's
actually closer there.
I'm also able to
take in consideration
things like popularity.
By definition, things that
have more foot traffic,
you're more likely to
be there because people
tend to spend more time there.
The same goes for geometry.
A place is not
specifically just a point.
It has a physical
representation.
So I'm able to understand by
using things like our satellite
imagery, which we talked about
earlier, how much space a place
actually takes up and what's
my relationship to that space.
And then we're able
to take advantage
of a lot of the
mobile signals that
are only available mobile
platforms like Bluetooth scans
or Wi-Fi scans.
So we're able to actually
understand and triangulate
from these representations of
all these different inputs.
And so based on
all those inputs,
and again, because
Google can understand
how users are navigating over
hundreds of millions of places
and actually applying
machine learning to that,
we can make a much more
educated recommendation
about where the user is, which
was a Moroccan restaurant
across the street.
So secondly, our mobile
libraries are easier to use.
And this is for a
couple of reasons.
First, as I talked
about earlier,
we maintain the place object
and we create these helper
methods that makes it easy for
you to get different metadata
about that place.
So whether it's getName
or getReviews or getURL,
you're able to actually easily
access that information,
the place object,
without actually having
to parse the JSON yourself.
And then the second reason
is, of course, these widgets
that I've talked about earlier.
So not only are you able to
take advantage of the logic
that some of these services
like autocomplete or PlacePicker
provide, but we're also
giving you the UI elements.
And these are controls that
are very common in many apps.
So why reinvent the wheel with
your precious developer cycles
when you could instead
be using that time
to actually work on the things
that matter to your business?
So you can leave these
sorts of UI elements to us.
Just plug it into your app
and then focus on the things
that matter to you.
And then finally, we've
prioritized performance
so our mobile libraries are
intelligent with how they're
actually making network calls.
We know that data is
precious, and especially
when you consider
developing worlds.
So we need to be
respectful of our users
and when we're actually
making calls to our backends.
And we also know
that there are often
familiar places that users
are frequenting over and over.
So we're actually able
to do smart things
like more on-device caching.
So we're actually remembering
if, for example, there's
information about a place
already available locally
on the device, then we
can just utilize that
rather than making unnecessary
costs to our backend
to fetch new, fresh data.
So we know that users
are fundamentally
creatures of habit.
And so they're going to the
same places over and over again.
So we can reduce
up to 90% of hits
that would be unnecessary
to our backend
because that information is
already available locally
on the device.
So today we traversed a journey
and we covered three parts.
We first looked at
our location stack
and fundamentally what
makes a place a place.
Second, we explored some
real-world use cases
and then the
corresponding services
that you can use
within the Places API
to take advantage of those.
And then finally, we
looked at our mobile SDKs
and how this best comes to life
on all the little computers
in our pockets.
So we're excited to see
where you developers take
your journey to create a sense
of place in your own apps.
A couple other callouts.
For those who are
watching on live stream
and for those in
the audience, if you
want to follow up on some
of the services and APIs
that we covered today, you can
check out our documentation
on places.
We also have more
documentation around some
of our mapping products.
And then yesterday
my colleague, Joel,
talked about making the world
your own via Google Maps APIs.
So if you didn't get a chance
to check out that session,
I encourage you to look
up that title on YouTube
and you can re-watch
the session.
We just talked about a sense
of place in your apps today.
And then immediately
following this session,
my colleague, Ankur, is
going to be walking us
through some new solutions
that we've built on top
of some of our Maps APIs.
So I encourage you
to stick around.
Or if you're on the live
stream, keep watching.
If you're unable to do that,
check us out on YouTube later.
So thank you for
having me today.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]